what okay kill em all up on Kennedy if  that I had a thought was challenged  bunking with the access code I'm the guy  killed at the kicks in ballet axel this  ideas from Jacob not ba you ready for  this I'm ready I feel like I'm riding a  dinosaur or something  [Music]  in the face okay I got this I got this  you got that yeah we need another person  on my show  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  we have had strangely many suggestions  we should play with our hands so we are  finally doing it  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so we're trying to shoot the Apple with  our table tennis back onto the knife and  see if we can slice it and I think I  broke the Apple have you got sliced it  [Music]  perfect slice almost in the middle can't  believe this actually worked remember to  subscribe here and check out previous  episodes there until next time